[Music]
so Chuck what's up so you know that
today is a very very special day
it is actually
World Teachers Day
very nice I didn't know there was such a
thing no there is such a thing but
that's not what I'm talking about it's
your birthday this is your birthday Make
Some Noise if it's
your birthday Make Some Noise if it's
okay all right so happy birthday October
5th yes it is my birthday yeah I'm born
a year and a day after Sputnik oh wow
and the same week that NASA was founded
oh my God you started the Space Race
okay I'll take credit for it there you
go yeah yeah I'm totally I all did it
all yeah yeah so yeah well happy
birthday but it is actually World
Teachers Day thank you which is you are
also
a teacher
um one and not only a professor but also
a teacher on a world scale much like one
of your uh Chief Inspirations uh none
other than Carl Sagan whose mantle you
have picked up and I'm sure he'd be very
proud to see uh how how you have carried
that mantle thus far well thank you
thank you so um I don't know how many
people know the story when I first met
him
and I've said it before but let me let
me lay it down the track right now okay
cool okay and so I known since I was
nine okay I thought you were gonna go a
totally different way just like so a
little people people do not know this
but Kyle Sagan was actually my Father
which actually that would be uh you are
my father Yes
actually no your father was a was also a
great man your actual father was a great
man you know Cyril Tyson so but anyway
uh human rights and uh civil rights
leader here in New York City yeah so but
anyway back to Carl back to Carl so my
interest predated my knowledge of him
all right I was so my in that sense my
interests were sort of homegrown within
me after a first visit to the Hayden
planetarium in New York City my local
planetarium which is where I now serve
as director so that trip it's I became
Star Struck so by age 11 as I've said
before I had an answer to that annoying
question that adults ask kids which is
uh when are you getting out of my house
no okay glad I didn't grow up in your
household
most people I think would answer to that
question what do you want to be when you
grow up right and so I would say
astrophysicist and and so it was deeply
anchored there and meanwhile I was uh in
the astronomy club I bought a telescope
with money I earned by walking other
people's dogs 50 cents per dog per walk
in the Glory Days of dog walking where
you didn't have to clean up their poop
right pre-proofer scooper laws that's
how old I am and so there I am and with
like I said I'm in the physics Club I do
astronomy things I I went to an
astronomy Camp over the summer went to
Stonehenge did research so I'm all in
all in by the way it's where I got the
idea for Manhattan henge having visited
Stonehenge when I was 14. and and so I'm
all in on the universe and so I'm
applying to colleges and one of the
colleges I applied to and who accepted
me was Cornell okay and Cornell is where
Carl Sagan was a professor okay and
apparently unknown to me the admissions
office said you know he might still be
Heming and on about this decision do you
think you can help us they sent him my
application he read my application saw
that it was Dripping with the universe
and he wrote me a letter
hand signed wow it said dear Neil I see
you're interested in the universe so am
I I'm paraphrasing here of course why
don't you come visit the campus I'll
show you around to help you decide if
you want to attend it was like because I
he was already famous then right all
right he'd been on The Tonight Show with
Johnny Carson and uh you know it's the
then version of of Jimmy Fallon and so
he'd written books so I knew about the
guy but who am I I'm just a 17 year old
high school senior why why what so this
so
I showed it to my parents I said let's
do it yes so
I got on a bus
from New York City to Ithaca New York in
December
and yeah yeah it's a terrible time it's
very very bad time to go there and uh
and he meets me in front of his building
and by the way it's on a Saturday okay
all right my boy was either already
there he came to meet me but it was on a
Saturday no nobody else was there no
support staff and he shows me around and
he does a badass thing he did a no look
reach behind him and pulled one of his
books that he then signed to me so a no
look reach means you wrote so many books
no matter what you touch is gonna be
something you wrote okay right I still
have that book of course it says to Neil
future astronomer Carl
all right so I did all this and it we go
for hours and hours and then it time it
for me to go back to New York he drives
me to the bus station and it begins to
snow not an uncommon reality and as it
began to snow he said
um
I don't know if the bus will make it
through
here's my home phone wow if the bus is
stalled can't get through
call me you can spend the night with my
family
and I thought to myself who am I
for him to treat me this way what why
who and then I you know what I said to
myself the whole time this is almost
surreal I said to myself if I am ever
as remotely famous as Carl Sagan
I will treat the next generation of
students
the way he has treated me
wow
and
it was it was
um
I I never forget that
and so it's and I would only see him and
greet him two or three other times in my
life since then it was not like we were
beer drinking buddies and I can't even
officially call him a mentor but what if
he did it broke his heart because you
didn't go to actually didn't go to
Cornell sorry yeah I didn't go that's
another story go to Cornell but but a
essential component of who and what I am
as an educator and as a scientist is
derived from observing him interact with
others passing a torch that needs to be
passed so that science is a continued
unbroken Arc from one generation of
seekers to the next
so
tip my hat
World Teachers Day yeah
if if you're not making a difference in
someone else's life
you're in the wrong profession
absolutely yeah
all right Chuck I don't think we have
time that's that's it that's a great
great story you know so much better than
the story of when I'm when I met uh my
my hero uh comedian just you know which
uh basically I won't say who it was but
it's a very quick story
um
um basically he went why are you here
and
um that was the end of our meeting
it was the opposite of Carl saggins
right
it was like you know I I and I was
opening for him oh okay that's why I was
there yeah okay all right now there was
an answer to that question but he asked
this question to say hello and
questioned it okay well why are you in
here all right it's like to see you so
anyway one last thing his Library okay
was donated to the Library of Congress
and in his library in all of his papers
they dug up this correspondence that he
had with me when I was a senior in high
school and that was put on display uh in
the Library of Congress
because they can probably do that for a
lot of people but I became somebody in
the world of Who You'd put on display so
I thought it was a very beautiful sort
of closure to that story
and it's really not closed because it's
open on the other side and I'm trying to
pass it all forward yeah well it's a
great great story there you go Chuck we
got it we got a call happy birthday
thank you thank you I'm feeling every
moment of my age
well I don't feel a day over you know no
I definitely feel with that
I feel exactly my age but uh and if you
don't know what that is go look up when
NASA got founded and then you'll know
all right uh it's a delight to do these
With You Chuck and a shout out
to the world Educators yes uh without
you we might as well all just move back
into the cave and occasionally I feel
like that's where we're going anyway so
try to help us prevent that all right
this has been star talk as always keep
looking up
foreign
[Music]